More than 250 million people live in a country
other than the one they were born in... in
other words, they’re immigrants.
And, my friends, this number won’t stop
growing.
In the last 50 years it has multiplied by
3 and only since the year 2000, the number
of immigrants has increased by 80 million!
That’s 80 million more people who’ve left
their country in search of a better life.
And as you can imagine, most of all the world’s
immigrants – more than 65% - have settled
in the richest countries, such as the United
States, Germany, Australia and Canada.
And it is precisely this fact, dear viewers
of VISUALPOLITIK, that is feeding, throughout
the world...
controversial, furious and bitter debates
on immigration.... and also, the discourse
of many populist movements.
In recent years, in Europe, for example, we’ve
seen a lot of populist and xenophobic parties
emerging... which have targeted immigration
directly.
What if they steal our jobs, put us in danger,
destroy our national identity, etc., etc.
But... perhaps, the most outstanding case
is that of Donald Trump.
A president who has made it clear, very clear,
that he really doesn’t like immigration...
except, apparently, under certain circumstances.
Check it out:
("President Trump balked at an immigration
deal that would include protections for people
from Haiti and some nations in Africa, demanding
to know
why he should accept immigrants from “s***hole
countries” rather than from places like
Norway".
New York Times)
Why on earth would Trump think that Norwegians
want to emigrate en masse to the United States,
when they are already richer than Americans?
In fact, more people are moving from the US
to Norway than the other way around.
But... let's not stray off topic.
Is immigration really a danger, a burden,
a step down?
Is the United States losing economic momentum
because of all the immigrants in the country?
Should the US stop the arrival of more foreigners?
Let's see.
If there’s one thing we can all agree on,
it’s that we live in an increasingly interconnected
world, that is, a world where it’s becoming
easier, faster and cheaper to go from one
place to another.
And where it’s also becoming easier to contact
our loved ones no matter where we are.
And... as you can imagine all these things
make the decision to pack up and move to another
country much, much easier.
That's why... if there were 90 million immigrants
around the world in the 60s, today there are
more than 250 million...
And you know what?
We can expect this number to grow strongly
in the upcoming years.
First, because it’s becoming easier to move,
and second because of the huge demographic
growth that many poor countries are experiencing.
So, my friends, the question is, are there
reasons to worry?
Listen up.
(A LUCKY BREAK?)
Whenever rich countries talk about immigration,
it sounds like they’re debating whether
or not to engage in some kind of charity.
And... you know what?
Nothing could be further from the truth.
Immigration favors economic growth, among
other things because most immigrants are adults
of working age.
Therefore, it’s calculated, listen up, that
since the year 2000, immigrants have been
responsible for 40 to 80 percent of their
main recipient countries’ workforce growth.
So let’s be honest without them, these countries
would be far less wealthy.
But yes I know.
This is all quite abstract, if you want we
can see exactly what has happened in one of
the countries where immigration has caused
a lot of controversy recently: the United
Kingdom.
In recent years, while some political groups
warned about the enormous threat that immigration
- including, check this out, immigrants coming
from other European Union countries - posed
to British jobs, identity, and way of life...
the truth is that the economy has placed very,
very different numbers on the table.
Never before in history, have so many people
been employed in the United Kingdom as they
have today-- neither in absolute nor relative
terms.
And, it doesn’t even matter if we exclude
immigrants.
Never before has the British population had
so many job opportunities as they do now.
And…. not only that, according to studies
from several British universities...
all these immigrants pay more taxes than they
get from the State and if that weren’t enough,
the UK is managing to attract more university
immigrants than any other European country.
In other words: the effect of this immigration
is very, very positive for the British...
and it’s also helping turn the United Kingdom
into a technological powerhouse.
Not bad, right?
Well...
You know what?
Despite Trump's fiery speeches...
The truth is that on the other side of the
Atlantic, things really aren’t that different.
Listen up.
(THE NORTH AMERICAN DREAM)
With just over 44 million people – more
or less the population of Spain – the United
States is in absolute terms, the country with
the most immigrants in the world…
However, just a moment... because in relative
terms...
things are different.
These 44 million people, represent just under
14% of the entire population.
To give you an idea, in countries like Australia
or New Zealand, for example, the percentage
is almost twice as high.
Now, here’s a question and you can’t look
it up:
What impact do you think immigrants have in
the United States?
Well dear viewers...
listen up:
Despite representing just under 14% of the
population, immigrants are responsible for
almost 25% of all businesses that open in
the United States; for more than 30% of the
companies in which venture capital funds invest
and almost half of all of Silicon Valley’s
high-tech start-ups.
And that's not all… according to a study
from the Center for American Entrepreneurship,
43% of the 500 largest companies in the United
States were founded either by immigrants or
by children of immigrants.
That’s 216 companies whose revenues surpass
$5 trillion each year and employ almost 13
million people around the world.
We’re talking about nearly half of the great
US economic powerhouse.
My friends, from Henry Ford to Elon Musk...
many of the great figures and iconic characters
of the United States weren’t even born in
this country.
But, just a moment...
some of you may be thinking, OK, SIMON, but
those are only a few immigrants, the most
educated ones...
What about the rest?
Well... the truth is, the numbers don’t
vary much there either: their entrepreneurship
and employment rates are also very high.
And they provide several other benefits, too.
For example, in a country that at the moment,
let's not forget, has pretty much full employment,
new immigrants reinforce the US’s competitiveness,
encourage the rest of the American population
to do more, and allow for many businesses
that would’ve otherwise not existed to be
created.
So in summary: immigrants reduce the population’s
average age, they have more children, are
more educated, are more enterprising, file
more patents, etc., etc.
And if you think about it for a second, it
all makes a lot of sense:
on the one hand, these people arrive to achieve
a better future, so they are willing to take
risks and work hard;
on the other hand, they have had different
experiences and education, and they can take
advantage of this to progress.
Think, for example, of the Italian pizzas
or the Mexican tacos that flood the US today...
and the rest of the world.
Well, despite these arguments… and of the
fact that never before have so many Americans
had jobs, politicians like Donald Trump still
don’t like immigration.
But you know what?
This isn’t the first time that US political
leaders have spoken out against immigration.
(THE PRECEDENTS)
My friends, this is by no means the first
time that the United States, the country of
immigrants, has had political campaigns against
immigration.
See, in the middle of the 19th century, the
political movement "Know Nothing" opposed
immigrants, particularly the Irish.... and
soon after, the Chinese had their turn.
Yes, you heard that right...
the Chinese!
During the second half of the nineteenth century,
many Chinese came to the United States...
and that triggered a rather hostile popular
reaction.
( From Seattle to Los Angeles, from Wyoming
to the small towns of California, immigrants
from China were forced out of business, run
out of town, beaten, tortured, lynched, and
massacred, usually with little hope of help
from the law.”
Immigration, a work of Library Of Congress.)
All this because, at that time, Americans
saw the Chinese as competition.
And in 1882 the Federal Congress itself approved
the Law of Exclusion of the Chinese, which
not only suspended the arrival of new Chinese
immigrants but, also, made the lives of those
who were already in the US quite complicated.
And that wasn’t all.
In 1924, after around 30 million people had
crossed the Atlantic Ocean to reach the US,
Washington established a quota policy that
greatly reduced the number of immigrants that
could arrive and also... vetoed immigrants
from southern Europe – such as Spain and
Italy –, Eastern Europe, Asia and Africa.
So basically, the few who could enter had
to be Anglo-Saxons.
And, more recently, in 1994, the then governor
of California, Pete Wilson, blamed Hispanic
immigrants for the state’s poor economic
situation… and
Do you know what he did?
Well... he launched a huge political campaign
against immigration and pushed the so-called
Proposition 187, a law that prevented access
to social, educational and even health services
for all irregular immigrants.
Including children!
It was so aggressive that just a year later
the supreme court declared it unconstitutional.
Well, the fact is that despite all these campaigns
against immigration...
existing research shows that states and counties
that historically had more immigration, now
have a higher income, less poverty, less unemployment
and better educational results.
So with all this data in mind, it might be
good for both the White House and the Capitol
to focus less on how to deport people and
more on how to strengthen access,
and to try to approve, once and for all, a
migratory reform that facilitates the orderly
arrival of more people... more workers, more
entrepreneurs and more researchers to aid
the great North American economy.
By the way, in a future video, which we’ll
try to make available very soon on our PATREON
page and later here on this Channel, we’ll
discuss each of the great myths about immigration.
But now, it’s your turn.
Do you think your country should reduce the
entry of immigrants?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did and don’t forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new videos.
Also, don’t forget to check out our friends
at the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine!
And as always, thanks for watching!